I know there was a lot of rumors back in
the day that really wasn't true Jennifer
Lopez sets the record straight about a
certain rumor we'll talk about music
movies this that and wherever I go
people be like what are you doing for
your skin I'm like okay the triple
threat opens up on Vogue series beauty
secrets hey guys Jennifer Lopez here I'm
very excited I'm about to walk you
through my dewy makeup look but I like
to have bright eyes and how was this for
an eye-opener she shuts down speculation
about how she gets that JLo glow I know
there was a lot of rumors back in the
day that I was like into all of these
expensive cleansers and I had to like
douse myself in lemare and stuff like
that that really wasn't true yep and
Jennifer goes on to drop gems it lifts
the face a little more and words of
wisdom until 25 or you get the face that
you're born with after that you get the
face you deserve at the end of the day
Beauty starts from the inside out you
can be useful in Timeless at every age
it's it's how you feel about yourself on
the inside so when you go into the
mirror and you kind of you know wash
that face and you wash things away and
it's kind of like letting the bad
thoughts go away it's kind of taking a
moment for yourself to say you know I'm
taking care of you the beauty breakdown
follows JLo's festive weekend I like
those Christmas sweaters baby her and
her hubby Ben Affleck kicked off the
holidays with a bash at their Hollywood
home
I'm so good and lucky for us partygoers
captured some musical moments inside
and the story sells E.T quote Jen and
Ben had so much fun at their holiday
party and everyone quote had a blast
what can I tell you we're just having a
good time and the Soiree is all part of
Jennifer's Christmas game plan as
another Insider tells E.T she's all
about starting quote brand new
traditions this year
come home
[Applause]
yep with the two enjoying newlywed life
seems like Jin's morning affirmation
pays off I also like to say a little bit
of an affirmation so I am in perfect
health always my family is in perfect
health always I am youthful and Timeless
at every age my life is full of
abundance joy and love
foreign
[Music]